I watched your movie last night and I
actually I they let me watch it at home
and I kept my wife awake I was laughing
so hard right Casa de me Padre the
entire movie is in Spanish yes as always
you are hilarious I don't know when I've
seen a movie quite like this I surely
enjoyed it yes completely different yeah
yes a lot of when I did a lot of the
press for the movie a lot of a lot of
interviews just saying why there's yeah
my concern for me yeah yeah there is
very strange stuff in this movie that
had me howling there is a sex scene in
the movie that is unlike any sex scene I
have ever seen yes where yeah how do you
describe this one well I'll tell you is
you have your hands on a woman's bottom
yeah yeah well it starts out as an
emotional embrace yeah to me and génesis
rodríguez who plays Sonya my so
beautiful so and so goodness we've we
finally break the tension of our like
for each other and we start making out
and then disrobing and then that just
transitions into a shot shots many shots
of butts yeah yeah me caressing just
hands karate-chopping no that was it you
do a move that I've never seen yes we
are doing this to her bottom and it's I
did this kneading yeah chops and just
awkward like I don't know what to do
on a woman's butt this looks like you're
landing a plane yeah
but the weird thing was I did not use a
butt double I was hoping that you did I
did I did not but mine is not the butt
you think it is mine looks like a shaved
woman's butt okay this is disturbing a
wait but I had to be pressed up against
Genesis the actress used a butt devil so
I had to be literally pressed up against
her and yeah well here's the thing I
know you're your wife yes lovely
vivica beautiful woman very nice free
everything mom what's it like I know you
guys have a trippin marriage you go home
and you tell her I just shot this scene
yeah I I went home and I walked in the
door she's like how was she today
nothing what nothing nothing
everything's fine why are you looking at
me like this immediate way to defense no
I had to literally sit down and say
honey I just shot one of the craziest
scenes I've ever shot we're pressed up
against a woman and I did this on her
buttocks and she just went that's okay
it's what you do she's a keeper
she's my wife we have a clip here from
Casa de meet Padre Oh what's happening
here tell us I've totally forgotten what
this clip is I think it's in Spanish
it's in Spanish and you're in it and I
am in it
let's take a look let's tie a Rondo
Hornsey a supernumerary way quiero la
muchacha de hurrah here los dos NOS
vamos
so dotted are a una oportunidad suerte a
mohair it alejo be real entirely in
Spanish 86 minutes yeah go straight from
here to the theaters they're leaving no
it's very very funny